brought to you by Final Fantasy 15
available on playstation 4 and xbox one
November 29th hey guys it is the 22nd of
November today my name is Jess and
here's the things that have been
happening in gaming first up today the
third season of tell tales Walking Dead
has been delayed but thankfully it's not
for too long season 3 will begin on
December 20 a month later than telltale
had originally suggested it would arrive
it's called a new frontier and will stop
yeah a young man trying to find his way
in the world in the wake of the zombie
apocalypse there will be five episodes
in total and a physical addition is
slated for release on februari 7 PS for
users who opted to preorder will be
gifted season 2 of tell tales Walking
Dead and the Machine theories as a bonus
while steam pre-orders yes I'm going
with that will get temp sent up telltale
have said that will be getting more info
on episode 1 at the game awards
understand the first next up the
relatively broken seamless multiplayer
of watchdogs to might be on its way to
being slightly left broken Ubisoft has
begun to enable the feature again
explaining the first phase of seamless
online multiplayer was brought back
online on ps4 earlier today and the plan
is to do the same with the xbox one
version later today the in game
multiplayer app allows you to invite
friends to cop hack other players worlds
and take part in bounty hunt which
should soon be occurring seamlessly if
all goes to plan you'll also be able to
seamlessly bump into other players in
the world at which will prompt you to
take on co-op missions and dead SEC
events these changes come alongside the
new one point 05 update which Ubisoft
said includes important crash fixes and
that improved stability finally smart
money seems to suggest that a new
Blizzard project is in the works the
publisher has posted two job listings
calling for lead software engineers on
the US career site the listings call for
workers with experience developing first
person for
games and makes note of the fact that
the successful candidate will be working
on quote an unannounced project that
utilizes a robust first-person engine
over watch is blizzards first and
currently only first-person game it's
too soon to say whether the new project
will be an expansion of sequel or an
entirely new game we should leave me
your thoughts and feelings in that
comment box head to gamespot the stories
on pokemon and Mass Effect Andromeda and
I'll catch you again tomorrow